the lack of critical thinking that we're
currently experiencing is a national
crisis over the last two years we have
seen crisis after crisis after crisis
unfold and there's just absolute
stupidity everywhere here's a perfect
example over the weekend bloomberg wrote
an article titled inflation's things
most if you earn less than three hundred
thousand dollars and there's two tweets
the first coming from the bloomberg
opinion handle it said inflation's
things most of you earn less than 300k
take the bus don't buy in bulk try
lentils instead of meat nobody said this
would be fun what the hell are they
talking about but that wasn't the only
tweet that they had then the bloomberg
economics handle went ahead and made it
worse they said from selling your car to
foregoing chemotherapy for your dog
there's tips on how to beat inflation
for going chemotherapy on your dog what
are these people talking about they've
lost their minds but it's not just
around inflation either here's three
more titles of recent articles that go
ahead and show what a clown world we're
living in the first is that the cdc
accidentally inflated children's covet
death numbers in a coding logic here
it's a pretty big mistake then we've got
this second one that says the brits are
told to work from home three days a week
and ban cars on sundays to beat putin's
energy crisis you can't go to work and
you can't drive your car absolutely
insane and then last but not least now
that we know the hunter biden laptop
story is true there's 51 intelligence
experts that refuse to apologize for
discrediting what ended up being a true
story whether you agree or disagree with
each of the nuances of each individual
story it doesn't matter what we are
watching is a lack of critical thinking
people are simply following like sheep
whatever they're being told by the
mainstream media you have to learn to
think for yourself before it's made
illegal as well i hope that you at home
are keeping your eyes open because this
clown world only continues as long as we
allow it hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time